مشهد يتكرر في النيجر بعدما شهد مماثله في
دول مجاوره حرق العلم الفرنسي ومهاجمه
مصالح فرنسيه وفي المقابل رفع علم روسيا
يؤشر المشهد الى وجود صراع بين فرنسا
صاحبه النفوذ القديم في غرب افريقيا
وروسيا التي زاد اهتمامها بالمنطقه في
الفتره الاخيره بعد اعلان انقلاب رحب به
قائد مجموعه فاغنر
المختفي عن الانظار قال في تسجيل منسوب
اليه انها لحظه تاخرت كثيرا للتخلص من
المستعمر حسب تعبيره لم يشير بجوجين الى
اي دور لفاغنر فيما يجري في النيجر لكن
وبالنظر الى انتشار قوات المجموعه في
المنطقه تتخوف الدول الغربيه من استغلالها
الوضع الحالي لدخول نيجر ايضا توجد قوات
مجموعه فاغنر في افريقيا الوسطى وليبيا
ومالي ويعتقد ان لها ادوارا مختلفه في دول
افريقيه اخرى
وتعتبر الدول الغربيه فاجنر وسيله روسيا
لنشر نفوذها في افريقيا ولم يصدر عن
السلطات الروسيه بعد تمرد قائد المجموعه
ما يشير الى تغيير او الغاء لدورها في
القاره الافريقيه في جوار مالي لا يخفي
النظام الذي تسلم السلطه بعد انقلاب عسكري
تعامله مع فاجنر في اغسطس السنه الماضيه
اكملت فرنسا سحب ثلاثه الاف جندي بطلب من
السلطات الماليه نقل نصفهم تقريبا الى
النيجر فيما يقدر عدد قوات فاغنر هناك
بالف مسلح ثم طالبت السلطات التي تسلمت
السلطه في بوركينا فاسو بعد انقلاب عسكري
ايضا فرنسا بسحب 400 من القوات الخاصه
امام هذا الوضع اصبحت النيجر الى جانب
تشاد اهم بلدين يستقبلان قوات فرنسيه يوجد
في النيجر حاليا 1500 جندي فرنسي هذا
الوجود سيصبح مهددا اذا لم يتم التراجع عن
الانقلاب وساءت علاقه باريس مع من
ولا يقتصر الاهتمام بالنيجر على فرنسا فقد
اقامت الولايات المتحده قاعده جويه
لاستخدام المسيرات في شمال شرقي النيجر
ونشرت 1200 جندي هناك انطلاقا من موقعها
الاستراتيجي تكتسي النيجر اهميه قصوى
لفرنسا والولايات المتحده في حربما على
الجماعات المسلحه في منطقه الساحل ولذلك
فارغامهما على المغادره سيشكل انتكاسه
كبيره تزداد قسوتها اذا اصبح موطئ قدم في
هذا البلد ايضا